the United Kingdom stands with our
allies in doing all we can to support
Ukraine against President Putin's war of
choice
we must ensure Putin fails in this
horrific Enterprise and his Ambitions go
no further
we were pleased to support lithuania's
leadership referring war crimes to the
ICC
I'm here today in Vilnius with our
Baltic friends because I want to say
that the UK's commitment to the baltics
and to Article 5 are unyielding
our Baltic friends know what's at stake
having long lived in the shadow of
Russian aggression and I admire your
courage
we're working together to deliver two
clear objectives
first Putin must lose in Ukraine we're
helping Ukraine defend itself our
defensive weapons from the United
Kingdom are now being used to stop
Russian tanks but we need to do more
secondly we must contain this aggression
we are reinforcing NATO's Eastern flank
and supporting European security through
the uk-led joint expeditionary Force
we are here in the Baltic region we lead
and have doubled our enhanced forward
presence in Estonia
our allies are leading
troops across the baltics
British Military Intelligence are
working with lithuania's military to
enhance border defensive including
in the slovaki gap
200 troops are doing joint military
exercises right now and we're working
together on Maritime security
at the NATO foreign ministers meeting
tomorrow
we will be working together to
strengthen our Collective defense in the
light of the change security situation
across Europe
in terms of supporting Ukraine with
defensive weaponry
the United Kingdom was the first
European country to give defensive
Military Support to Ukraine
and we are now also supporting with the
humanitarian Aid we've pledged 220
million in Aid support to Ukraine and
we're the top European donor and we will
do more
we've also been at the Forefront in
tightening the Vise on the Kremlin
through sanctions and it's vital at this
juncture that we keep our foot on the
gas
we've worked with the US the EU and G7
to cut off funding for Putin's War
Machine kicking Russian Banks out of the
financial system we've also shut our
airspace to Russian planes and we're
fast forwarding sanctions against
Russian oligarchs but we need to go
further
we need to make sure no Russian bank has
access to Swift and we need to go
further on reducing dependency on
hydrocarbons from Russia including oil
gas and coal
we've also launched sanctions against
Belarus for aiding and abetting
aggression
I will be raising these issues at the G7
tomorrow and also at the European Union
Foreign Affairs Council alongside the
United States Canada and Ukraine who
have also been invited in these
extraordinary circumstances
this is a struggle not just for
Ukraine's freedom and self-determination
but for all of our freedom and security
by continuing to respond with strengths
we will together ensure that Putin loses
and we stand with our brave allies here
in the baltics to do just that